Prof: Now,
let us begin today with just
some general issues that I think
are very pertinent to the
reading of the Quixote.
How significant is it that
the Quixote is written in
prose, not in verse?
The prose, it is because it is
the prose of the world,
of everyday life.
Every day life is prosaic,
and this is the life that is
being depicted in the
Quixote.
It is devoid of the order and
the rhythm of poetry.
Hence the novel,
from now on,
will be written in prose,
with exceptions.
Remember my allusion in the
last lecture to the Divine
Comedy and the order of
the Divine Comedy,
and that central line in the
very middle of the whole comedy
alluding to Dante and the highly
structured nature of that poem
down to the tercets and to every
line,
with its rhyme, with its meter.
The same, of course,
is true of the Aeneid,
with its exquisite form and
shape.
In the Quixote what is
represented is,
I repeat, the prosaic.
The prosaic is that which is
common and ordinary and not apt
to be expressed in verse,
although there are,
as you have seen,
in some episodes, bits of verse.
Now, another general issue
after the Marcela episode--
remember, when Don Quixote
interferes and doesn't allow
anyone to chase her into the
woods--
we have to ponder if Don
Quixote is a hero.
If he is, how does he differ
from Ulysses,
from Aeneis,
from the Cid,
from Roland and other heroes of
the preceding western literary
tradition?
Is he mostly a moral hero?
This is something that we
should ponder as we continue to
read the novel.
And the last general issue that
I'd like to bring up is,
again, the issue of irony.
José Ortega y Gasset,
who was a very important
Spanish philosopher of the
twentieth century,
the most important Spanish
philosopher of the twentieth
century--
He's known in the English
speaking world mostly for a book
called The Rebellion of the
Masses,
and also for...
he has a very important book on
the Quixote,
Meditations on the
Quixote,
and yet another that is even
better,
known than that called The
Dehumanization of Art,
which is about the avant-garde,
the art of the avant-garde--
He said: "Irony is instead
of saying what we think,
we feign to think what we say.
Irony constitutes an unfolding
splitting up into two such as in
the prologue of the
Quixote,
when the narrator splits into
two by creating the friend who
comes to advise him.
In irony there is this
splitting because there is a
need of another who knows and
who understands the double
entendre."
Irony can become sarcastic but
not in Cervantes.
Cervantes's irony,
as you have all ready noticed,
I'm sure, is mild and humorous
rather than cutting or
sarcastic.
The dialogue on which the book
depends so much is essentially
ironic,
because we can see the errors
of both protagonists as they
speak with each other,
errors that they point out to
each other.
In the case of Don Quixote,
as you will notice,
once and again he points out
the errors that Sancho makes in
speaking,
but Sancho will also catch Don
Quixote in a few mistakes
himself.
Now, we move to one of my
favorite parts in the book which
are the scenes in Juan
Palomeque's inn.
You have to remember the names
of these characters.
His name is Juan Palomeque.
I'm sure you did not quite
retain this name.
He is the innkeeper,
the most important innkeeper in
the first part of the
Quixote.
Among the most famous and
important episodes in Don
Quixote are those at his
inn.
I have already spoken about the
importance of inns in the plot
of the Quixote when
commenting upon the first inn,
in which Don Quixote was
knighted, if you remember.
Karl Ludvig Seilig,
retired now,
Professor at Columbia
University, wrote:
"Formally,
structurally,
thematically the inn is an
important focal point,
a place of configurations and
conflations."
Inns in the Quixote or
in Cervantes are derived from
the picaresque tradition where
they figure very prominently,
in books like Lazarillo de
Tormes and Guzmán
de Alfarache,
that I have mentioned here
several times.
In those books,
the inns play a similar role.
In fact, as we remarked,
the first innkeeper was a
retired pícaro and he
tells with relish his life of
picaresque adventures,
where he visited or stayed at
the most notorious picaresque
emporia throughout Spain.
I also spoke of how inns
provide a kind of archaeology of
society,
using that metaphor,
because characters from
different social classes and
professions meet in them.
The one run by Juan Palomeque
is, by far, the most important
building in Part I of the
Quixote, even more important
than Don Quixote's house.
In par two, there will be other
buildings, as you will discover.
I, again, emphasize that it's
good to remember the names of
these secondary characters,
like Juan Palomeque,
who play significant roles in
the novel.
They sometimes,
as I have all ready mentioned,
have interesting names,
in some cases the names are
interesting because they're so
common,
as Pedro Alonso--remember?--the
neighbor who picks him up,
or Pero Pérez,
the priest,
and so forth.
In the case of Juan Palomeque,
his last name has something to
do with pigeons;
'paloma' is a pigeon in
Spanish.
The '-eque' ending
doesn't sound very good,
like '-ote' in Quixote,
Palomeque, so it's a last name
that is mostly funny.
Now, if the road--as we have
come here,
as we have arrived at the inn
coming on the road--
was for the most part a sunny,
bright,
realm, and this will change in
the episodes after the inn.
The inn is in a kind of a
chiaroscuro--
I'm sure you've heard this
word, but I guess I'm determined
to teach a lot of very pedantic
words that you can use in
further life,
even if you become a lawyer or
something,
'chiaroscuro' in Italian
means 'bright dark';
it's a combination of darkness
and brightness,
and it's normally associated
with Baroque art.
And I will be speaking about
the Baroque in later lectures
because the cliché
is that the first part of
the Quixote is mostly
Renaissance,
and the second part is Baroque.
This is one of those
clichés,
so I'll be talking about the
Baroque.
But, so it is a dark place.
In Juan Palomeque's inn,
people eat,
fight, have erotic encounters,
and live in very close
proximity,
very close proximity,
as you have noticed,
making for a great deal of
friction,
real and metaphoric,
in this case,
as the characters rub against
each other in the very confined
quarters of this inn.
Now, at the inns the humor is
very theatrical,
they are like a stage--and,
in fact,
in later episodes the inn will
become really a stage with
characters coming in and out,
like actors on a
stage--Theatrical in the sense
of slapstick comedy;
slapstick comedy,
because it's a comedy in which
characters hit each other with
that stick that has a slap and
makes it sound like it's a very
hard blow,
you hit somebody--pow!--and it
sounds.
It comes from the commedia
dell' arte.
Commedia dell'arte was a
kind of Italian theater of the
fifteenth century in which there
was no dialogue;
the characters just slapped
each other, and kicked each
other, and so forth,
and went around.
The word in Spanish for
slapstick is very funny;
it's called
matapecados--I bet even
the native speakers didn't know
that word--Matapecados,
sin killer.
It's a stick with which you hit
somebody else and--So,
it's a slapstick kind of
comedy.
This comedy involves physical
violence, mistaken identities
and rowdy behavior.
In episodes such as these,
Cervantes displays his talent
for comedy,
which he put to good use
writing his very successful
entremeses or
interludes--
Remember, the
entremés is the
one-act funny play that is
usually staged between acts of a
larger play--
Humor culminates in these
episodes,
when Don Quixote's imaginings
suddenly appear to mesh with
what is happening in the tawdry
world in which he finds himself.
He takes the innkeeper for a
nobleman in his castle,
as he did with the first inn,
and Maritornes as a damsel in
love with him,
when she is really an ugly
prostitute on her way to meet
the carrier,
who happens to be lodging
there, too.
The point seems to be that even
the rather concrete reality,
tangible reality of the inn can
be transformed by the characters
needs,
desires, and imaginings,
because this inn is as far as
possible from a castle and the
characters as far as possible
from those in the romances of
chivalry.
Don Quixote's erotic desires
have been aroused by the
innkeeper's daughter.
Remember, the innkeeper has a
young daughter whom we imagine
as a mere teenager and is
described in the text as,
quote: "a very comely
young maiden."
This episode is the most
explicit erotic display by Don
Quixote in the entire book,
erotic in a sense of explicit
sexuality,
is the most explicit in the
whole book.
But more than anything the
episodes at the inn are an
instance of the social,
being subverted by erotic
desire, that of the carrier and
Maritornes,
as well as Don Quixote's.
The ensuing violence involves
even the law,
as the representative of the
Holy Brotherhood intervenes,
and remember,
brings Don Quixote with a
candleholder in the darkness of
the inn.
What does this show?
Well, that the sublimated
eros of literary
tradition has its counterpart,
perhaps it's real driving force
on these unleashed erotic forces
that propel the characters to
violence.
Cervantes is not moralizing
here, and he hardly ever does.
All he seems to be doing is
showing the real,
as it were, subconscious of
literature,
the counterpart,
let's say, of the romances of
chivalry and the pastoral,
what lurks underneath the
romances of chivalry and the
pastoral.
This is the reason for the
darkness, it represents all of
these forces as opposed to the
pastoral.
Pastoral literature always
occurs in daylight,
and the eclogues--eclogues are
long poems on a pastoral theme,
the most famous were by
Virgil--The time of an eclogue
is the time span of a day,
so here it is the complete
opposite;
the darkness revealing the real
forces underneath those pastoral
poems, and so forth,
and the romances of chivalry.
Now, let me go over the cast of
characters in Juan Palomeque's
inn.
As you, I'm sure,
have noticed already,
Cervantes relishes in the
presentation of characters drawn
from the lower strata of society
and tries to give a rounded view
of them,
meaning that,
along with their coarseness,
they often display kindness and
human understanding.
These characters,
again, are drawn from the
picaresque, but also drawn from
the extensive juridical or
judicial documents of the
period.
Spain generated a very
extensive judicial system in the
sixteenth century with hundreds
and thousands of documents
stored in archives about the
comings and goings of
characters,
such as the ones we see here.
But Cervantes,
as I always emphasize,
tries to give a rounded view of
these characters drawn from the
lowest classes and also from the
criminal classes,
rounded view showing that they
can be kind, also.
And they are not stereotypes,
they are individuated or
individualized by their moral
and their physical features.
The best case is
Maritornes--Maritornes,
the character about who I am
going to speak now,
whom I hope whose name I hope
you will retain.
I have mentioned her a couple
of times, and I want you to
remember her name from now
on--They all have individual
features, physical as well as
moral.
The first character is the
innkeeper Juan Palomeque,
el Zurdo, the left-handed,
lefty--I'll speak about that in
a minute.
Remember, I told you to look
for details.
This is a significant detail,
as you will see a little later.
Look for details--his wife and
the daughter,
that's the family running the
inn.
Number two, Maritornes.
She is an Asturian wench,
meaning, who in spite of her
profession is kind towards Don
Quixote and Sancho--
Remember, that she gives him a
drink at the end when he's
leaving and so forth.
He's very kind of her--Notice
that she is from Asturias.
There are maps of Spain on the
website and I have been urging
you to use them so that you can
situate yourself.
We have now met the Basque or
Biscainer, as Jarvis calls him,
who's from the Basque
countries, remember?
I spoke about the Basques;
we met the Yanguesans,
who were really from Galicia,
northwestern Spain,
and here we have someone from
Asturias.
The Galicians are of Celtic
origin, they're something like
the Irish.
They play bagpipes like the
Irish--I hate bagpipes--but the
Galicians are known for their
bagpipes.
I will speak more about the
Galicians as we go on--But
Maritornes is from Asturias,
a northern province,
a region of Spain.
They are very proud,
the Asturians,
because the Reconquest,
the war against the Moors,
began in Asturias,
so they take great pride in
that,
that it began right away,
after the Moors occupied Spain.
So the fact that she's Asturian
might be a joke on the part of
Cervantes, they are very proud,
and here we have an Asturian
prostitute.
And Cervantes was obviously a
proud Castilian,
and he has enough Castilians
who are not exactly beings,
being one to be proud of,
but he has a view,
a particular view,
of the people from various
regions of Spain.
So Maritornes is a wench from
Asturias.
She takes pride in being
reliable in her professional
dealings as a whore.
She keeps her dates,
in this case,
with catastrophic results.
Though Maritornes is no
princess as Don Quixote
imagines, she is responsible
within her profession and
generous.
Cervantes is not a moral
relativist,
but he has an understanding of
human frailty and the tumbles of
individual fate--
If you read with care,
you will have learned that
Maritornes is a prostitute
because of a series of
misfortunes have brought her
down,
not because she's inherently
inclined to sin--
and as I have said,
and I emphasized she is ethical
within the expectations of her
trade she delivers.
Cervantes also liked to show
how morality can be a code
coherent within a given
context--
You will see this better in
Part II,
when there is a gang of
outlaws, and within that gang,
within its rules there are sets
of ethical behavior--
In his own case,
as you have read the essay by
Durán in the
Casebook,
which you should have by now,
you will know that the women in
Cervantes's family because of
financial pressures were
involved in questionable
activities at certain points--
and I do hope that you read
that very fine and succinct
essay by Durán from which
I quoted a little bit in the
last class emphasizing the fact
that Cervantes was an insider
and outsider at the same time in
Spain.
Now, I'm going down the list of
characters at the inn:
the carrier,
a muleteer, who happens to be
an acquaintance,
or even a relative,
of Cide Hamete Benengeli,
the alleged author of this
story.
It's another instance of
Cervantes's self reflexivity.
Here we have a character who is
related to the real author.
Now, it is true that
Moriscos--fellows of Moorish
origins--
tended to be carriers like
this, but Cervantes is making,
again, another hilarious
connection between the fictional
and the real worlds of his
novel.
Now, going down the list of
these characters--
and I'm doing this as this had
been a play,
because, as I said,
the inn is very much like a
stage--
there is an officer from the
ancient Holy Brotherhood of
Toledo,
who represents the law,
and he's the one who hits Don
Quixote on the head with a
candleholder,
and I explained in the last
class what the Holy Brotherhood
is,
or was at the time,
and it plays an important role,
because it is the police force
that is pursuing Don Quixote and
Sancho.
Now, finally,
there are Pedro Martínez
and Tenorio Hernández,
who are among the rowdies who
participate in Sancho's blanket
tossing at the end of this
episode.
You remember when they go out
and toss Sancho on a blanket,
a practice that was mostly
reserved for animals during
carnival time.
They would do it to poor dogs,
to blanket toss them like that.
A point to consider is that
these are rowdies,
but not inherently evil
characters--again,
in spite of their social
station.
Notice, again,
the very common name Pedro
Martínez,
who happens not to be the
current pitcher for the
Philadelphia Phillies,
formerly with the Boston Red
Socks and the New York Mets,
he is the Dominican pitcher
who's now making a comeback with
the Philadelphia Phillies and
who happened to be named Pedro
Martínez.
Being named Pedro
Martínez is like being
called Peter Smith in English,
so it's not unlikely that this
coincidence would happen,
but whenever I get to this
episode I mention this and
wonder how many baseball fans
there are in the crowd,
because I am,
as you probably know,
a baseball fan and also a
writer, I write on baseball,
and so forth.
In any case,
this Pedro Martínez is
the not the pitcher for the
Phillies.
He is a rowdy who participates
in this blanket tossing of poor
Sancho.
Now, these characters,
like Don Quixote himself,
tend to have physical defects
or scars.
The source here,
if there has to be a specific
source is La Celestina--
Remember, the work that I have
mentioned several times,
in which the protagonist is an
old whore and go–between,
who has an ugly scar on her
face.
The faces of these characters
are scarred by time,
by temperament,
by profession,
by crimes, by illness,
by class.
In this, Cervantes is also very
much like Velázquez;
he finds beauty in the ugly,
and this is very much a part of
the modernity of Cervantes and
Velázquez.
He finds beauty in the ugly,
the deformed,
even the monstrous;
and some of Velázquez's
characters and Cervantes's
characters are monsters.
These characters have features
that make them apt to be
displayed, to be seen,
to be admired,
like Velázquez's
midgets.
And so, I have asked Elena to
provide us with some examples of
Velázquez's midgets.
I am not going to remember
their names.
Is that clear enough,
or should I lower the curtains?
As you can see,
Velázquez has painted
this midget with a book,
so that you can see the
relative size,
as I mentioned in the last
class.
He's very tiny,
indeed, and that physical
feature is that which makes him
a specific individual,
and it is that deformity that
makes him interesting,
esthetically interesting.
These are others.
Some of them have,
as the one in Las
Meninas,
and will it see in a minute,
a kind of an air of idiocy on
their faces as if they were also
retarded.
Next.
This one, I think,
is the most famous one and do
you remember the name of this
one?
I had the name.
Yes, I think this one is El
Niño de Vallecas or
Sebastián de
Morra.
Student:  Morra.
El de Vallecas viene despues.
Prof: Yes,
these are characters in the
court.
They were used for
entertainment and for amusement.
Next.
Yes, this one has,
you can see,
an air of idiocy in his face.
Next.
All right, and then we get to
Las Meninas,
back to Las Meninas,
with that flat round face,
and that gesture,
and that face of sort of
idiocy,
I wonder if even Down's
Syndrome or something like that.
Such characters can and were
turned into spectacles for
amusement as is done,
by the way, with Don Quixote in
several episodes because of
their peculiar features.
It is their defects that make
them esthetically valuable and
different,
but Velázquez was a
master at showing individuals
features and suggesting a
relationship between these and
the personality of his subjects.
He did this even in the
portraits of kings--I think I
mentioned in the last class,
some of these Hapsburgs had a
large jaw;
because of inbreeding in these
lines such features were
emphasized genetically,
and so he did not stop at...
and he would paint the kings
like that.
It is the same as Cervantes's
penchant to characterize based
on peculiarities of body and
mind.
Don Quixote is thin and
cerebral, Sancho is fat and
physical.
Each, however,
is mental or cerebral or
physical, in a particular way.
But while focusing on these
ugly characters,
let us not forget Marcela's
perfect beauty and that of other
young women and men about to
appear in the novel.
These follows models of beauty
derived from Renaissance art,
which in turn derived from
classical models.
Think of Botticelli's Venus,
and The Primavera,
variety is the norm in the
Quixote with frequent
contrast between extreme
ugliness and stunning beauty.
You will find this in
characters such as Dorotea,
that are about to appear in
this central part of the novel.
At the inn, the first character
with a physical defect is Juan
Palomeque himself,
who is left-handed.
Until very recently,
left-handedness was considered
a defect, and in school children
were forced to use their right
hands.
My Basque maternal grandfather
was left-handed,
and he was forced,
physically forced,
to use his right hand in
school;
otherwise he would be beaten.
And when he went home to do his
homework he would do it
left-handed, which is more
comfortable, and as a result,
he could write with both hands.
But I'm trying to emphasize
that because now,
of course, we are very far from
thinking that left-handedness is
a physical defect--
How many left-handers here?
You are a real minority.
It's okay--But,
of course, now it's common.
I have relatives who are
left-handed and so forth,
but the most remarkable
character in terms of physical
traits is Maritornes.
Her name, by the way,
could suggest an inversion of
virginity, or the opposite of
virginity, Mari,
Maria, Virgin Mary,
-tornes, turns around.
Maritornes would be the reverse
of a virgin.
She's, in fact, a whore.
Let me read the descriptions of
Maritornes.
First, on page one-eleven of
your book:
"There was also a servant
in the inn,
an Asturian wench,
broad-faced,
flat-headed,
and saddle-nosed,
with one eye squinting,
and the other not much better.
It is true, the gracefulness of
her body [I changed that word
from the translation]
made amends for her other
defects.
She was not seven hands high
from her feet to her head;
and her shoulders,
which burdened her a little too
much, made her look down to the
ground more than she cared
to."
Remember, again,
the midget in Las Meninas,
that we just saw;
the face is broad,
flat, the nose deformed,
her being stooped or
hunchbacked suggests her being
inclined,
literally, to the ground,
to the base,
to that which is low,
not to the heights.
Her defective eyes had a touch
of grotesqueness,
but also signals limitations in
perception that are at the core
of what happens at the inn in
the dark,
when they can't see each other
very well.
These are only her physical
attributes.
Later, when Don Quixote seizes
Maritornes we get the rest of
the picture on pages 114-115:
"Thus she encountered Don
Quixote's arms,
[she being Maritornes],
who caught fast hold of her by
the wrist,
and pulling her towards him,
she not daring to speak a word,
made her sit down on the bed by
him.
Presently he felt to feeling
her smock, which,
though it was of canvas,
seemed to him to be of the
finest and softest lawn.
She had on her wrist a string
of glass beads;
but to his fancy they were
precious oriental pearls.
Her hairs, not unlike those of
a horse's mane,
he took for threads of the
brightest gold of Arabia,
whose splendour obscures that
of the sun itself.
And though her breath,
doubtless, smelled of last
night's salt fish,
he fancied himself sucking from
her lips a delicious and
aromatic odor.
In short, he painted her in his
imagination in the very form and
manner he had read described in
his books,
of some princes,
who comes, adorned in the
manner here mentioned,
to visit the
dangerously-wounded knight with
whom she is in love.
And so great was the poor
gentleman's infatuation,
that neither the touch,
nor the breath,
nor other things the good wench
had about her,
could undeceive him,
though enough to make anyone
but a carrier vomit."
Now, we move here to a kind of
phenomenology of ugliness,
how does it feel,
how does one perceive ugliness,
of the repulsive,
as Maritornes more contingent
and secondary characteristics
are itemized.
The reader is given this chance
features depending on what she
wore and how she smelled on that
particular night,
and what here breath was like,
owing to her last meal.
The phrase: "the other
things good wench had about
her" is a polite
circumlocution a periphrastic
way of sparing the reader of
further probably more revolting
traits.
That's what that phrase stands
for there.
The aesthetics of the ugly and
repulsive is very much
contingent on temporality,
on the passing time that wears
down bodies and endows them with
undesirable though temporary
qualities.
Deformities are contingent
individuating,
particularizing,
in contrast to perfect models
that are timeless--
Contingency,
by the way, since I'm using the
word a lot: that may or may not
happen,
possible, happening by chance,
accidental,
fortuitous, conditional,
these are definitions of
contingency--
This is the aesthetic
counterpart of the statement by
Don Quixote,
when he's mauled by the
windmills that he took for
giants.
Everything is subject to change.
It is the realm mischievous
enchanters that alter things,
like walling up his library and
turning this damsel,
this beautiful princess that he
thinks he's holding,
into this repulsive whore.
Don Quixote mistakes to apply
the model of beauty,
the Renaissance blonde model of
beauty,
which is blonde and beautiful
young woman,
to the grotesque Maritornes.
His mistake reveals,
however, that what he passes
off as sublime love is really
lust.
The episode lays bare
appropriately in the middle of
the night, and in total darkness
Don Quixote's subconscious.
We should not miss the point
that as a prostitute,
an embodiment of lust,
Maritornes is the opposite of
what one would normally consider
sexually desirable.
We are here at the lowest point
of love, at its basest.
So the episodes at Juan
Palomeque's inn,
fraught with erotic violence
and culminating with Don Quixote
and Sancho's violent bowel
movements and vomiting,
are like a phantasmagoria in
which the basic,
the most basic drives behind
the protagonists' actions are
staged as it were.
They are reduced to their
oral-- these characters,
these protagonists--are reduced
to their oral,
anal and even genital stages,
if we're going to use Freudian
terminology;
they are reduced to that basic
level.
Don Quixote's desire for the
innkeeper's daughter shows his
physical desires,
which are surely behind his
transforming Aldonza Lorenzo.
Aldonza Lorenzo,
remember, is the young woman
near Don Quixote's village that
he turns into Dulcinea,
so we see what is behind that
turning Aldonza into the sublime
Dulcinea.
Aldonza is not ugly,
as we will see.
She is a brawny, but attractive.
Don Quixote's lust for her is
typical of an upper class older
gentleman for a lower class
woman,
whom he considers sexier and
more sexual than women of his
social class.
Spanish literature is full of
situations in which a lustful
aristocrat tries to ravage a
peasant woman;
all of European literature is
full of this.
Don Juan, of the famous Don
Juan tradition is such a case,
but there are others that I
will mention during the course
of the semester.
Don Quixote's and Sancho's
bodily evacuations provoked by
Fierabras's balsam dramatized
the violent forces behind their
basic drives to live.
Remember that Don Quixote
claims to have the recipe or the
prescription for this balsam,
that he learned in the romances
of chivalry that if you drink it
will make you whole again,
even if you have been sliced or
cut in two.
You drink the balsam and,
boom!, you're made whole again,
you're cured.
And he asks for the
ingredients, and he makes it,
and they drink it and,
of course, the results are
horrendous,
because both Don Quixote and
Sancho have violent bowel
movements and vomiting,
and all of that.
This is particularly so with
Sancho,
who, by the way,
will defecate again soon out of
fear--
if you have gotten to that nice
episode with the fulling-hammer.
But note that the balsam is
supposed to restore their bodies
to make their physiques whole
again,
erasing the ravages of violence
and,
more broadly, of time.
The balsam would erase those
ugly physical features or scars
that identified them.
Here, the balsam stands for
something that would erase those
marks on their bodies,
the marks that I have been
speaking about.
Excreting is a mock form of
purification,
a rejection of the material
world that they have ingested.
Ironically, Don Quixote does
get better;
perhaps, medically speaking,
he needed to be cleansed out,
and so taking this which turns
out to be a violent laxative
makes him feel better,
but Sancho almost dies,
because he vomits and has
diarrhea,
and everything that you saw
there.
I will return to this unsavory
topic soon.
Now, the flimsy construction of
Juan Palomeque's inn leads us to
a topic that I have mentioned
several times before:
improvisation,
evident in Velázquez's
gesture--
He's improvising,
he's going to paint--
and discussed at length in the
prologue to Don Quixote.
Juan Palomeque's inn is the
most important building in Part
I and is an internal emblem,
I think, of the book's careless
genesis and structure,
or its deliberately careless
genesis and structure.
I'm equating here the inn and
its construction with the
composition of the book Don
Quixote.
The inn is the one shelter the
protagonists do find repeatedly
in Part I,
but they enjoy no protection or
peace within its walls,
because it is so dilapidated
that it barely keeps them out of
the elements.
It is not a meaningful and
fulfilling end to the road,
but a way station.
That is, is not a home to
return to, and it's meaningful,
and it shelters them,
and gives them solace,
and so forth.
It is just a way station,
its parts are in a sorry state
of disrepair and do not match
harmoniously with each other.
The camaranchón
is the word in the Spanish in
the original.
It's camaranchón,
in the original,
or attic, where Don Quixote's
bed is set up:
"gave evident tokens of
having formerly served many
years as a hayloft."
Sebastián de
Covarrubias,
whom you must remember from my
earlier lectures--
remember the lexicographer who
wrote the first dictionary of
the Spanish language and
published it in 1610-- says that
'camaranchón' is
derived,
obviously from the Latin
'camera,' chamber,
and it's a disparaging term for
the highest spot in a house,
an attic or loft,
where old junk heterogeneous by
its very nature is stored.
This the reason the stars can
be seen through the gaps on his
flimsy roof,
which is why it is called in
the Spanish an
"estrellado
establo"
or starlit loft,
that is, if you think of the
inn like this,
the camaranchón
would be here.
So, from the inside,
you could see the roof,
which has holes,
and it's starry because you can
see through the roof,
the holes in the roof,
you can see it's a very
primitive drawing,
but you can see through its
roof, you can see the stars.
This suggests that the inn was
originally a small house to
which additions were made
haphazardly,
incorporating the stable and
it's hayloft to its living
quarters to accommodate more
paying guests.
Also, a roof so full of holes
that the stars are visible from
within comically suggests that
the inn has cosmic connections,
as did Greek,
Roman and Aztec temples,
as well as the Renaissance
counterparts by the alignment to
celestial bodies.
In other words,
in Classical architecture,
in Aztec architecture,
the temples were aligned to the
stars,
to the constellations,
so that the building would be
part of this cosmic world.
Do you understand what I'm
trying to say?
The buildings were aligned in
such a way.
Also, such a star spangled
ceiling would be nature's
counterpart to the elaborate
ones of certain palaces,
in which zodiac signs were
often depicted in the roof.
Which is the closest example we
have to that today,
those of us who live in the
northeast, that we see it all of
the time?
Student: Grand Central.
Prof: Grand Central
Station!
The next time you go to Grand
Central Station,
look up--not too long,
or they might take your
wallet--
but look up,
and you will see that the roof
has drawn on it all of the
constellations.
It is as if there were no roof,
as if you could see actually
the stars, and that is a device
used in Renaissance palaces.
And so, it is an ironic
allusion to it,
that the roof of this very
humble building is starlit.
Against the background of the
inns ramshackle improvised
architecture,
such illusions are hilarious,
and highlight that it is no
architectural jewel built
following a careful plan and
classical models.
It would seem as if during its
construction,
which was gradual and ruled by
chance,
everything in it has been
transformed by contingency--
there is contingency again--and
the passage of time.
"Many years"
it says in the quote that I
read you.
The provisional nature of its
furnishings is evident in Don
Quixote's bed,
which, quote:
"consisted of four not
very smooth boards upon two not
very equal trestles".
Unquote.
Predictably,
during the free for all
provoked by Maritornes nocturnal
appointment,
the mule driver climbs on it
and makes it collapse,
quote: "the bed which was
a little feeble and its
foundations not of the strongest
being unable to bear the
additional weight of the carrier
came down with them to the
ground."
You remember that scene,
I'm sure.
The improvised patchwork
architecture of Palomeque's inn
reflects that of the structure
of the Quixote Part I,
with its interpolated stories
of which you're going to read
some very soon.
And also Cervantes's notorious
errors, and even Don Quixote's
practice of letting Rocinante's
whim dictate the direction of
his journey.
Now, the Quixote is the
only classic that about which
there is a whole bibliography
about its errors.
All classics have--you know,
they say that Homer fell asleep
here,
and something happened,
and the Odyssey is not
perfect,
and this and that,
but the errors in the 1605
Quixote are a notorious
part of it,
and a lot has been written
about them,
because improvisation can lead
to errors,
and there are quite a few in
Part I.
Let me list some of them.
There are errors that the
characters make that cannot be
attributed to Cervantes but to
their haste,
that is, the haste of the
characters,
their carelessness,
but all of that is within the
fiction.
These are the errors that later
on you will find,
Dorotea makes them while
playing Princess Micomicona,
Don Quixote makes a few;
in chapter IV he says that
seven times nine is
seventy-three--this could be a
typo.
Later he says that the biblical
Samson removed the doors of the
temple, when it was the gates of
the city of Gaza that Samson
ripped off.
And there are other kinds of
errors that can be blamed on
Cervantes and his editors.
For instance,
the mistaken chapter titles and
numbers.
The title of chapter X
reads--not in your translation,
where it was fixed,
but in the original--it reads:
"Concerning what further
befell Don Quixote with the
gallant Basque and the danger in
which he found himself with a
band of Galicians from
Yanguas."
But the episode with the Basque
is over,
and the fracas with the
Yanguesans doesn't come until
five chapters later,
after the Grisóstomo and
Marcela interlude.
Chapter XLIV appears in roman
numerals as chapter XXXV,
and so on.
But the grandest mistake was
the theft of Sancho's donkey,
which you have not reached yet;
but in chapter XXV the reader
finds out that Sancho's donkey
is not just missing,
but that it was stolen!
After twelve chapters,
we started worrying about the
lost of recovered donkey,
here reappears gradually.
His trappings are mentioned,
until in chapter XLVI he is
there, again,
miraculously in the inn's
stable!
This is all in the first Juan
de la Cuesta 1605 edition--Juan
de la Cuesta was the publisher
of the 1605 edition.
Actually, the very first
printing was late 1604,
but it was given the 1605,
if you want to be really
pedantic.
But it's the 1605 date that is
given--This is all in the first
Juan de la Cuesta edition,
the princeps edition.
But in the second 1605
printing, it's also well--
a new printing had to be
made--also by Juan de la Cuesta,
the theft of the donkey appears
in chapter XXIII and it's
recovered in chapter XXX,
and Cervantes has added a
series of paragraphs to justify
all of this--
these are hilarious paragraphs.
The writing in these added
passages reads very much like
Cervantes's prose to me,
though not to other scholars,
who think that this is somebody
else writing,
so editors have incorporated
them into the final version of
the model.
A critic, named Lathrop,
thinks that the additions were
by the editor,
and believes that all of these
mistakes were put it the
Quixote on purpose by
Cervantes.
Once you have something like
this, there are critics who can
claim anything,
that it was not a case of
careless improvisation but a
plan to simulate it.
The issue is mute for me.
In either case,
willed or not,
the mistakes reveal a hasty,
shoddy composition,
and imperfection and lack of
finish,
as it were, and fits with the
topic of improvisation
introduced in the prologue,
when the narrator,
or Cervantes,
claims that he doesn't know how
to write the prologue and
presents himself as someone who
is not in total control of his
creation.
Now, back to Juan Palomeque's
inn.
I hope you have understood my
equating the improvisation and
the ramshackle character of the
inn, and that of the 1605
Quixote.
Now, Sancho's blanket
tossing--I must mention the last
event at the inn,
because Sancho never forgives
Don Quixote for not defending
him,
and the failure of his master
to act is something that casts
doubts in his mind about Don
Quixote's courage.
Don Quixote justifies it
because he claims that he's not
supposed to enter into battle
against commoners,
and that Rocinante froze.
The importance of this episode
is that Cervantes is building up
the relationship between his two
protagonists,
which will deepen in the next
episodes,
first when Sancho helps to cure
Don Quixote when he's wounded by
the shepherds defending their
sheep,
and later when Don Quixote,
angry at Sancho for laughing at
him,
strikes his squire--You
remember when Don Quixote hits
him over the head--
This deepening relationship is
one of the great virtues of the
novel.
Cervantes displays a profound
and caring knowledge of human
nature and of the
transformations of human
relationships;
it's something to learn from
the book.
This is new for a fiction,
that their relationship
transcends the social
differences between them and
becomes profound and complicated
because of these spats that they
occasionally have.
The following episodes follow
the same pattern.
Don Quixote and Sancho mistake
what they see with catastrophic
consequences.
It's the same pattern
established in the episode of
the windmills.
The first is the battle with
the herds of sheep--that I hope
you found as hilarious as I
always do when I reread it.
Don Quixote is,
again, fooled by a real world
that seems to conspire to look
like what he has in his head.
In this case,
the sheep reflect what you must
have read in Elliott about the
importance of sheep farming,
and of the wool industry in
Castile--
It's still very important,
and I have been suddenly in a
Castilian town and a whole sea
of sheep come by,
they are being herded to the
north or to the south,
as the case may be.
Wool was a very important
product of Castile,
as you have read in the
Elliott, and,
of course, this sheep at the
distance could look like an
army.
So Cervantes is reflecting here
not only the reality of everyday
life, but also the broader,
socioeconomic realities of
Spain of the period.
Don Quixote translates
everything that reminds him of
the world or romances of
chivalry into their language.
His arguments with Sancho and
others about the nature of the
real are one of the sources of
humor in the novel,
of course.
Here, Cervantes displays his
own gift for linguistic
invention and parody.
The names of the knights
involved are hilarious,
as is his description of the
imaginary battle,
has a mock epic quality.
Don Quixote,
hurt by stones whose names,
almonds, they're called at one
point,
understate their ability to
hurt, lose its teeth,
as he had before lost part of
an ear.
These are the scars of time on
his body that I have mentioned
before.
His body has diminished as the
work progresses,
contributing to his sorry
appearance and leading to the
name that Sancho gives him in
the next episode.
Notice that Don Quixote kills
several sheep and that he has,
again, been involved in a
fight.
Hence, he has committed crimes
that come under the jurisdiction
of the Holy Brotherhood,
so besides the disputes about
the real and the parody of the
romances of chivalry it must be
noted that Don Quixote and
Sancho are criminals who are
fugitives from justice.
Now, I want you to--I'm sure
you did--that Don Quixote and
Sancho vomit on each other,
here.
And I want to ponder about this
little episode.
We already saw the purging
involved in the character's
evacuations, but here,
I believe, that there is
another suggestion.
I was going to read you that
passage, but the time is short,
but I'm sure you remember it.
Vomiting here and in the inn
suggest the existence of a
concretely repulsive language of
pure meanings.
The mouth, amidst concrete,
it's a language whose effect is
repulsion, mutual repulsion,
but that is never a form of
communication.
One vomit elicits--that it is
nevertheless,
a form of communication--one
vomit elicits the other.
It is in this sense a pure
language, an ironic fusion of
words and things.
If you think that words merely
reflect reality,
vomit is reality itself
expressed as words,
this is what I'm trying to say.
Vomit contains objects,
not signs, and produces bodily
effects as when,
in the case in the next
episode, when Don Quixote smells
Sancho's feces,
another expression on the part
of Sancho,
and he asks him to move away.
This consideration of language
dovetails with all of the
meditations about language and
literature that are in the book,
and it is very appropriate.
I think that it should occur in
an episode,
where there is such a marvelous
display of literary language in
the description of these battles
and all of these knights.
So we have that literary
language, and then,
this concrete language of
vomit, when they express each
other in such a way.
I think that I'm going to leave
the next two episodes for the
next class,
the one about the dead body,
because there is very
significant moment there when
Sancho names Don Quixote The
Knight of the Sorrowful Figure,
and also the one of the
fulling-hammers,
to which I have just alluded
because of this hilarious moment
when Sancho defecates out of
fear,
and so we shall move on with
next series of episodes,
too, which take us to the core
of Part I.
The core of Part I,
which are the episodes that
take place in the Sierra Morena.